nylon stockings make me think of Melanie
Griffith and working girl but they
actually have an interesting past and it
involves the US Army gravy juice and
department store riots until the 1930s
women wore silk in nylon stockings
because having your legs uncovered was
not acceptable but then World War two
happened the US military began buying up
nylon and silk and using it to make
parachutes and tires and cords so women
donated their stockings to the war
effort the official motto for women
during World War two was make do and
mend wartime ads told women that they
needed to keep up appearances so when
life gave them lemons women in the 40s
they made liquid stockings it was a make
up for your legs kind of like
self-tanner it looked like stockings if
applied well women even drew the seam
line on the back of their calves and
this was not easy
some salons offered it as a service but
if this foundation wasn't around women
used gravy juice that brownish hue
mimicked the color of liquid stockings
and worked soon after the end of World
War two DuPont the big name in stocking
manufacturing said they would be
producing women's nylons again and in
1946 a store in Pittsburgh announced
that finally they had them roughly
40,000 women showed up only to find out
13,000 pairs were available fighting
ensued and 1946 became known as the year
of the nylon riots obviously DuPont got
their act together and by the end of
that year the nylon Depression ended and
out went the gravy tides thank goodness
you
you